everybody's got a question
I'm task IJ hey Justine I was just
wondering are you this big of a dork in
real life as you are online well Sara
let's cut you a clip and you can decide
I guess that's probably a yes all those
asked where did you get that t-shirt
Universal Studios how this works its
sound activated there's not a big noise
I don't know if you've noticed the leaf
is going the wrong way I suppose that's
the easy way to avoid a lawsuit best
video response ever even though it's not
a question it's amazing
thanks for other fun ask a JEP a--so
don't forget to leave comments make
video responses and ask me questions on
Twitter and I'll see you guys in the
next episode peace out